[Music]
all right
violence mastaba yeah me Rambo
[Music]
your mother mr. Fenimore Ando
poor time I thought all my teeth and
[Music]
we're glad to welcome you to the next
episode of our exclusive interview
program today we're visited by one
sebastian moroccan AKA Juan Pablo
Escobar
son of Colombian drug lord lord pablo
escobar head of the medellin drug cartel
Colombia's most powerful drug dealer and
most wanted man during the 90s
good afternoon Sebastian hello good to
see you why do you oppose the official
version of the authorities according to
which your father was killed in a
military operation I understand you have
your own version I am guided by what
really happened not by one of the
possible theories I am well aware that
the real version is inconvenient for the
ruling circles of Colombia and perhaps
not only them if you ask the Americans
they'll say that they were the ones who
killed him and if you ask the Colombians
it was the Colombian government in fact
as far as I know neither of them did it
[Music]
in the 80s Medellin was considered one
of the most crime-ridden locations in
the whole world
it was here that drug lord Pablo Escobar
added the infamous cartel
the gang made millions of dollars
selling cocaine and his leader killed
anyone who stood in his way even though
the cartel was responsible for thousands
of deaths Pablo remains a popular figure
among the country's poorest people in
some parts of the city he was even known
as Colombia's Robin Hood Medellin is
also a home to a close friend of
Escobar's they call him papa
he confessed to murdering 250 people and
organizing two and a half thousand
killings he spent 23 years in jail for
the crimes
[Music]
I'm a professional killer I killed for
money I also killed alpha lawful respect
for Bob lescovar
yeah we good and skill Viper 6 even for
people do
if Pablo Escobar's had order means to
kill my own father for harming our
organization in the mid 80s Pablo
Escobar's cocaine Empire came under
attack the Colombian government signed a
treaty with the United States that
allowed local drug lords to be
extradited to the USA it was a huge
problem
Escobar's say whether a grave in
Colombia than a cell in the US the US
will sentence us to 60 or 70 years of
life terms we started planting bombs to
kill government's ministers journalists
and judges we had kidnapped politicians
so they had amended the constitution and
stopped Colombians being extradited
median is know all around the world
thanks to public media Escobar Covidien
[Music]
how did you manage to save your life
after your father's death we paid for it
we gave absolutely everything that my
father left us in the inheritance
property works of art cache cars
motorcycles and planes
everything we gave everything we had
first my father's enemies came to us and
took what they wanted threatening us
with weapons what was left was taken by
Authority and this is very unfortunate
because at the end even with all the
money that they got from us they did not
compensate for the damage we done to any
of my father's victims why do you oppose
the official version of the authorities
according to which your father was
killed in a military operation I
understand you have your own version I
am guided by what really happened not by
one of the possible theories and well
aware that the real version is
inconvenient for the ruling circles of
Colombia and perhaps not only them if
you ask the Americans they'll say that
they were the ones who killed him and if
you ask the Colombians
it was the Colombian government in fact
as far as I know neither of them did it
there was a mafia group called los bebés
which the United States and Colombia
provided assistance and protection to
but there was in no way involved in the
operation that eventually led my father
to commit suicide in fact the following
album for more than 10 years my father
was the most wanted man in the world and
no one could catch him because he knew
that he could be found with phone
tracking technology as he did the same
with many of his animals however on that
day he made more than seven personal
calls saying his own name this indicates
that the father wanted to be found
imagine that a person who told
all my life not to pick up the phone use
that that day more than seven times is
in addition he knew that the place which
he was calling was under heavy military
control Anita you said that your father
could have sent drugs to Miami at any
moment without any problems as it was
facilitated by some corrupt agents of
the American Drug Enforcement Agency
what role do you think the u.s. plays in
the drug business unfortunately I must
say that there is a close connection
between the drug ban and the enormous
revenues that are not being declared
Latin Americans are accused of
benefiting from this the most yes if the
drug business works well the Latin
American cartels get very rich but in
the drug trafficking hierarchy they're
not the richest the richest are the
cartels which no one talks about have
you ever heard of those in charge of
cartels in Miami New York Los Angeles or
Chicago
it seems that such information is known
only in relation to those regions that
are south of the US border the top of
the pyramid its head is missing it
almost seems like Colombian drug dealers
produce drugs in Colombia bring him to
United States buy them and consume them
themselves but that's not how the drug
business works in fact the Americans buy
drugs for all the cartels of Mexico
Colombia and other countries then they
dilute them increasing the weight by
five times or more
they buy a kilogram of the purest
substance and make up to five to eight
kilograms of drugs out of it they pay
Latin Americans twenty or thirty
thousand and they earned 200 or 300
thousand from the same volume that money
never leaves the United States by the
way the same thing happens in Europe
Asia everywhere so this is not about
criticizing the United States here we're
dealing with corruption in many
organizations including the u.s. just
think back to how control tighten after
September 11 attacks now we're forced to
take off our shoes before each flight
what about drugs have their price
increased or has there been a deficit of
data no everything remains as it was
drugs are being ignored therefore it
seems to me that this business is
surrounded by incredible hypocrisy
Americans fill their pockets with drug
money to arrange festivities for
themselves and in Latin America they
turn to violence the difference here is
that the money received from the drug
business is in such regions as Latin
America goes to finance the bloodshed
while in America it goes to finance
their celebrations